- This right here
(screen tapping)
is the hottest battleground
for the future of automotive revenues.
The dashboard.
See, while you may only
really use this screen
for music, navigation and calls in the...
Oh, in the future, it's set
to be used for a lot more.
Traditional automakers plan
on using this space to sell a
suite of features and services
in a market that some analysts estimate
will be worth some $1.5 trillion by 2030.
But at the same time,
tech giants like Apple
and Google are pushing
to gain deeper control
of your vehicle and take
over more of your dash.
Now, battle lines are being drawn.
So who is winning the
battle of the dashboard?
Let's find out.
No, please don't.
Quite enough of that.
Now, I know I've said this before,
but if the car that you're driving
doesn't already receive
downloadable upgrades
and updates over the air,
then there's a strong chance
that the car that you
buy in the future will,
and that's because there's set
to be quite a lot of money in it.
Or as Tesla CEO Elon Musk
said in an earnings call.
- [Elon] We could sell
for zero profit for now
and then yield actually
tremendous economics in the future
through autonomy.
- GM has said it expects
to generate between 20 to $25 billion
in revenue from software-enabled
services by 2030.
Stellantis has forecast
roughly 22.5 billion
for the same time
and Accenture predicts
that digital services
will make up a whopping 40%
of global automotive revenues by 2040.
Now, that's crucial for these automakers
because right now, they're
struggling to make money on EVs.
- The profit margin on
these are much smaller
because the batteries are still expensive
and they haven't scaled yet.
- That's Mike Colias who
covers autos for WSJ.
- For the next decade,
investors are kind of wondering, well,
how are you gonna bridge that shortfall
in the profit margins that you're used to
on your big internal combustion?
The answer to an auto executive is, well,
we're gonna have all this digital revenue
and subscription services.
- So what do these
automakers plan on selling?
Well, at the basic level,
there'll be the usual offerings
of music and entertainment,
as well as navigation services
to things like parking
spots, valets, EV chargers
and gas stations.
Then there's subscriptions
to physical in-car options
that used to be add-ons, like
heated seats, more horsepower
or improved handling.
But one of the most lucrative
subscriptions is set
to be autonomous driving.
It may not be here yet
but that hasn't stopped some
automakers betting big on it.
Or as Musk said.
- [Elon] We expect our
vehicles over time will be able
to generate significant
profit through autonomy.
- Now, some of these upgrades
are set to be accessed
through smartphones and computers,
but if automakers are gonna
start selling through the dash,
they're gonna need to get
someone out the way first.
- CarPlay is the smarter,
safer way to use your iPhone in the car.
- [Narrator] Chances are
your car is compatible
with Android Auto.
- Yep. Apple CarPlay and Android Auto.
See, for years, automakers'
own infotainment systems lagged
behind that of smartphones,
mainly because cars operate
on longer product cycles than smartphones.
- 10 plus years ago,
the car companies I think thought
they could do this interface on their own.
They tried.
The infotainment touchscreens
in the cars weren't very good.
And so Apple and Google came up
with these solutions to
essentially mirror your phone
on the touchscreen of the car.
And a lot of consumers now rely
on this as their main
interface for the car.
- Now, for a while, this
partnership is working.
Dash screens were pretty
small and the smartphones
didn't really have much
interaction with the car itself
but now those screens are getting bigger.
- We designed the new Android Auto UI
to take advantage of those larger screens.
- [George] And tech companies
are reaching deeper into the car.
- There's an opportunity
for iPhone to play an
even more important role.
- In 2022, Apple announced
that not only would CarPlay be able
to take over the whole dash,
including the instrument cluster
but that the software would
reach far deeper under the hood.
- [Narrator] Tune your car's radio
or change your temperature
without ever leaving
the CarPlay experience.
This is just a taste
of what the next generation
of CarPlay will bring.
- That means that Apple
could potentially access some
of the very features
that automakers are trying to monetize.
And we all know how good Apple
and Google are at selling
downloads and subscriptions.
- I mean, that's what
Google and Apple do, right?
I mean they offer you apps and
features to pass your time.
So it's a battle for that space.
- I spoke to Apple and Google
but neither would tell me
about future automotive plans.
But even if Apple and Google
don't monetize their offerings,
their software still takes over the dash.
(door clicking)
- If you've got a tech
giant sitting in between you
and your customer, it's
gonna make it a lot harder
to you monetize that stuff.
- So it may not be much of a surprise
that GM has stopped
supporting Android Auto
and Apple CarPlay on future EV models.
- I know that GM considered
letting CarPlay live alongside
of its new interface,
but they ultimately felt
like they were just gonna
be fighting for eyeballs.
- That decision was met
with immediate criticism.
- Yeah, I mean, I heard from
a lot of people who said
I'll never buy another GM car again.
And I think GM knows that and
to that extent, it's a gamble.
- So is this the beginning
of the end for CarPlay
and Android Auto in cars?
Well, not exactly.
See, even though these
softwares won't be supported
in future GM EVs, the company still plans
on running its own infotainment system
on a version of Android's
operating system.
So Google will still be in the car
and despite GM's actions,
a few automakers appear
to be following suit.
For now at least.
- I asked a number of
executives from other companies,
almost all of them said, no way.
We have no plans to remove
those from the cars.
I think they see that as
potentially hurting sales.
- But that could all change.
See, right now digital
services only make up
around 5% of automotive revenues.
But as that percentage starts to increase,
don't be surprised
if you see more automakers
start to unplug the smartphone.
(upbeat music)